did Kim Kardashian finally make her
social media come back seemingly so the
36 year old reality stars Facebook page
had its first update on Monday night
this glam shot of Kim's sitting in a
chair while looking at one of her two
cell phones was uploaded the pic was
captioned quote downtime hashtag lumi
collab but there were two other posts
that went up shortly after one last
minute halloween costume linked to
kimmies app by her assistant Steph
Shepard and an adorable throwback snap
from Halloween seemingly posted by Kim's
sister Kourtney nothing will really
prepare you for this if in fact it is
the Keeping Up star this would mark the
first social media posts since the Paris
robbery that occurred earlier this month
back in action but Kim has slowly been
getting back to quote normal life she
stepped out in Los Angeles last week for
all three of husband Kanye West's life
of Pablo concerts at the forum sources
tell ET quote Kim is definitely ready to
start getting back to her normal life
little by little she's taking it day by
day and isn't pushing it it was really
tough for me
you